[Arabic recitation]
regarding
the various types of najasa.
And we had
entered yesterday into a sub-chapter
a few exceptions
from the eighth and final type of najasa
that the author mentioned, which was a
maytah, the dead animal, the dead
carcass.
And the author had mentioned three
exceptions
to the dead animal. We mentioned two of
them yesterday.
The first one
is
any dead
aquatic animal.
And likewise, the dead locust,
they are exempt from this.
from najasa. Number two,
another exception from a najasa is
any
animal or insect that does not have
flowing blood as usual animals that have
flowing blood. And so, he gives examples
such as flies and ants and bees. So,
various insects.
The third exception that he makes
is
[Silence]
So,
the third and final exception that he
makes
is
that part of the animal,
irrespective of any animal that it comes
from,
which
is technically
on the animal, but it doesn't have blood
flowing through it.
Okay?
Now, the author doesn't mention that
exactly, but this is the illah that the
scholars, the jurists of Islam, have
identified.
So, he mentions
the bones
of an animal,
the horns,
the nails, the claws, the hair,
the feathers of an animal, all of these
things, the tusks,
right? All of these things are
considered to be pure.
Now, if we were to look,
what is the commonality between these
things?
What is the common thread? What is the
thing that exempts these things
[Arabic recitation]
and there's not known to be any
companions who differed on this topic?
None of them.
There's not known to be
any companions who differed
on the purity of these aspects of an
animal, any animal,
whether it be
a an animal permissible to eat or
impermissible to eat, whether it was
slaughtered properly or improperly,
these elements are all considered to be
pure.
The bones, the claws, the teeth,
the horns, tusks, hair,
right?
Feathers.
We were to say, "What's the common
thread?" Well, the common thread, as
Shaykh al-Islam mentions, is that there
is no blood that flows through these
things.
These things are considered to be
things that are pushed out such as hair
or nails and these things are more or
less dead. They don't have any feeling
in them. They don't have nerve endings
in them a lot of times.
Right?
And so these things do not have blood
vessels
and they're not necessarily directly
nourished.
they are more of a a byproduct and they
do not move on their own. They need
muscles to move them.
Right?
So
he then mentions
what al-Bukhari used as an evidence in
his Sahih.
In Sahih al-Bukhari
he mentions the statement of az-Zuhri.
Ibn Shihab az-Zuhri, one of the Tabi'in.
Ibn Shihab az-Zuhri, he says I met and
lived
during the time of the
scholars from amongst the Salaf,
[Arabic recitation]
anhum.
Oh
the major Tabi'in.
And I encountered all of them to
use these elements of any animal in
their combs, in their brushes
as utensils, you know.
And they I don't recall any of them
viewing this as being impermissible.
Az-Zuhri is telling us. Az-Zuhri is a
Tabi'i and so this means that he's
speaking about the companions and the
major Tabi'in of his time.
He's saying this is something that was
pretty much common knowledge at his
time.
Also he mentions the narration of
Hammad. Hammad is also
one of the Tabi'in.
And his official fatwa was that there is
no
problem with using the feathers of a
dead animal.
Using the feathers of a dead animal.
And so,
these things can be very relevant. if
you notice certain types of heavy
brushes
use
boar boar hair in brushes, right?
Or let's say ivory or
something that's made out of the tusks
of elephants and things that. All
of these things are permissible.
they are not considered to be filthy and
they are permissible to use as the
[Arabic recitation]